and keep their operations going until
the next growing season
vaccinating americans providing
economic help for families getting our
children back to school
safely those are the three
main goals of this plan
all of these goals have one thing in
common it's about investing in
people it's about putting people
first the american people first
over our nation's history the policy the
policies that have truly
lifted people out of poverty and moves
them forward have invested
in people from
our land grant universities to social
security
and medicare and medicaid to the civil
rights act to the children's health
insurance program
to increasing the minimum wage
and these are all policies i'm proud to
say
created and supported by democrats
investing in our people helps american
families
and it helps our economy too we've seen
these democratic
policies create more jobs when you look
at the numbers
mr president just when we look at the
numbers
under which policies and which
presidents have we seen
more good-paying jobs and over and over
again
it's democratic presence because of the
way
that we invest it's what we do how we
invest
to create opportunity to give everybody
a fair shot to succeed
to invest in people and opportunity
those things have created
better economies and more jobs so
broadly we are committed on making sure
everyone shares in the prosperity of our
country
and these policies create the conditions
necessary to help people
dream big dreams and actually
achieve them
it's a new year it's a new congress
it's time to act it's time to end this
pandemic
give families the economic support they
need
and get our children safely
back to school this is the moment
this is the moment we need to think big
we need to be bold we need to lean in on
policies that
we know work
because they've worked before americans
know how to meet the moment
and our moment is now
thank you mr president i yield the floor
[Music]
that's the absence of a quorum if that
is necessary
the clerk will call the role is baldwin
[Music]
um
so
foreign
my
[Music]
[Music]
oh
mr president
the senator from new mexico ask
unanimous consent to
dispense with the quorum call without
objection
mr president 50
million americans including 17 million
children
are facing food insecurity because of
this public health and economic crisis
with black and latino families more
likely to go hungry
in new mexico one in three children
and one in five adults are at risk of
hunger
in the wealthiest country in the world
this is simply unacceptable
the budget resolution focuses on getting
relief to the people
who need it most beginning
with an extension of the 15 increase in
supplemental nutrition assistance
benefits
through september of 2021.
increasing snap benefits has proven to
be one of the most effective forms of
economic stimulus
and it has the dual benefit of allowing
families to
purchase the food that they need to stay
healthy
as well as supporting businesses that
accept
snap dollars the budget resolution also
bolsters the wic program to ensure that
children and their mothers have access
to a nutritious diet
necessary for healthy development an
important
investment in the future of our country
this funding increase is especially
significant for
states like new mexico where nearly a
quarter of
children are born into families with
incomes
that fall below the federal poverty line
in addition to addressing hunger this
resolution includes critical support
for the people who grow our food produce
our food our farmers and ranchers
in new mexico farmers and ranchers who
were already struggling due to drought
conditions
face new challenges due to covet 19.
shuttered restaurants left chili growers
and dairy farmers
without their customer base and
scrambling
to find new markets ranchers experience
long delays at
meat packing plants where workers were
hard hit by coven 19.
those workers need help too the pandemic
also made it harder to find workers to
cultivate the land and
tend to the animals this resolution
also supports a provision i advocated
for to provide
debt relief for minority and
disadvantaged farmers and ranchers
who did not receive their fair share of
cobit relief
under the last administration it is sad
that
societies are judged by how they treat
their most
vulnerable it's sad
because not everybody opens their eyes
to see how it should be measured
the senate must act for the families and
children facing hunger and for our
hard-working farmers
and ranchers those that are producing
food picking food preparing
food and getting it to market and
stocking the shelves
we must pass this budget resolution
i thank you mr president i yield the
floor
and i note the absence of a quarrel
the clerk will call the roll this
baldwin
[Music]
[Music]
wow
uh
wow
foreign
[Music]
so
do
hmm
crazy
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
do
hello
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
this
mr president the majority leader i ask
unanimous consent the quorum be
dispensed with
without objection mr president i ask
unanimous consent that the senate be in
a period of mourning business with
senators permitted to speak therein for
up to ten minutes each
without objection
[Applause]
mr president pursuant to the provisions
of senate resolution 27
i ask unanimous consent that the senate
proceed to the consideration of senate
resolution 32 submitted earlier today
the clerk will report
senate resolution 32 to constitute the
minority party's membership on certain
committees
for the 117th congress or until their
successors
are chosen
is there objection to proceeding with
the measure
without objection i ask unanimous
consent the resolution be agreed to the
motion to reconsider be considered made
and laid upon the table with no
intervening action or debate
without objection so ordered mr
president
i ask unanimous consent that when the
senate completes its business
today it adjourn until 10 am thursday
feb 4.
further that following the prayer and
pledge the morning hour be deemed
expired the journal proceedings be
approved to
to date the time for the two leaders be
reserved for their use later in the day
and morning business be closed
further that upon the conclusion of
morning business the senate resume
consideration of senate conres 5
the concurrent resolution on the budget
further that the time from 2 o'clock to
2 30 p.m be equally divided between
senators graham and sanders
and that following their remarks all
time on the budget resolution be
considered expired
is there objection without objection
so ordered if there's no further
business to come before the senate
i ask that it stand adjourned under the
previous order
the senate stands adjourned until 10 am
tomorrow morning
you